الان غاره اسرائيليه جديده استهدفت منزلا
في مخيم النصيرات قبل قليل بالتاكيد هذه
الغاره استهدفت منزل ماهول بالسكان ودون
سابق انذار والحديث يدور عن عدد من
الشهداء نتيجه تدمير هذا المنزل على رؤوس
ساكنيه قبل قليل اضافه سبقه غاره
اسرائيليه وقصف اسرائيلي استهدف شقه سكنيه
في مخيم المغازي ادت الى استشا اربعه
فلسطينيين ووصول عدد المصابين الى مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح وايضا الطواقم
الطبيه تمكنت من انتشال جثمان شهيد وعدد
من المصابين من مخيم البريج المنطقه
الوسطى بمخيمات الثلاث النصيرات والبريج
وايضا المغازي تتعرض منذ نحو ساعه لغارات
اسرائيليه تستهدف منازل ماهوله بالسكان
وايضا قصف مدفع كثيف يستهدف ممتلكات
المواطنين ومنازلهم وايضا المؤسسات العامه
والط الطرقات الرئيسيه مع توغل اسرائيلي
على التخوم الشرقيه لمخيم البريج وايضا من
المحور الجنوبي للمخيم بغيه احكام السيطره
عليه واطباق الحصار عليه لدفع من تبقى
داخل المخيم للخروج منه وسط اشتباكات
عنيفه تدور منذ يوم امس وحتى الان في شرق
مخيم البريج بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هنا في يونس
لازال الوضع على حاله من ناحيه استمرار
القصف المدفعي تحديدا على المناطق الشرقيه
من المدينه وايضا تحليق الطائرات الحربيه
وطائرات الاستطلاع على ارتفاعات منخفضه
وسبق كل هذه التطورات سلسله من الغارات
الاسرائيليه استهدفت عدد من المنازل في
المنطقه الجنوبيه تحديدا في مدينه رفح وسط
المدينه غاره اسرائيليه دمرت منزلا على
الرؤوس ساكنين جميع شهداء هذا هذا المنزل
هم من الناز ز حين الذين اجبرتهم قوات
الاحتلال على النزوح من المنطقه التي
يقتلون بها في مدينه خانيونس الى مدينه
رفح ثم باغتت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه بعدد من الصواريخ ما ادى الى
استشهاد اكثر من
20 فردا جلهم من النساء والاطفال بالاضافه
الى اكثر من 50 اصابه بين عدد من الاصابات
تقول المصادر الطبيه في المستشفى الكويتي
في رفح انها خطيره نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل على مختلف المناطق في القطاع